yeah but it's a discussing undermining
of the democratic process this is
legitimately talking about these guys
are presidential candidates
yeah I mean this is a lot of bloviating
about how great Trump is like no one can
compare with his it is a statement about
himself what's he gonna no this is the
statement released by president
president Trump if I watch his official
statement I'm not that good everybody
I'm doing an okay job perhaps but maybe
you shouldn't vote for me are those from
Chris
yeah it's a senior senior advisor is
there anyone else is there anyone else
this is from Chris Lucifer this is It's
the Trump campaign he's gonna talk he's
gonna pump himself up you know what I
mean it's out of touch he doesn't know
he hasn't been listening to the next
plan if he doesn't think that anyone
imagine a Salesman come in your house
and being like I have these vacuum
cleaners they're okay I guess yeah but
if you're lying it if you come to my
house and you know that a vacuum cleaner
is not as good as another one and you're
like this one's better I'm gonna be like
okay you're a liar get out do you think
that Donald Trump believes that the
vague has better policy plans than Trump